what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today brooklyn nine-nine yeah
we're on patreon yeah hit the like
button we eat all the crap by now that
we always say
okay thanks for thought for editing down
the highlights let's watch this
man charles has been so happy and
confident ever since he hooked up with
that professor at the captain's party
she has tenure and also has 10 years
times two
older than him that sucked
he could take it down just a smidge if
you like pina coladas dead guy charles
sorry
sexy train is leaving a station check
out this caboose and he's wearing jeans
great job boyle
i see stephanie beatrice and peacock
commercials now
playing a cop
with a suspicious husband nice jeans
boyle those are surprisingly low waisted
eyes up here gina i'm more than just a
piece of ass
bad not bad an unlicensed
driver takes the vix down under the bqe
robs my gun point these are stranded
unfortunately because they're tourists
and our perp is not caucasian we don't
have a clear idea of what he looks like
he was either latino arab or mexican oh
god
[Music]
we recently met at the african-american
gay and lesbian new york city
policemen's association uh yes that name
is quite a mouthful just call it the
atlantic park
that's just wondering i mean i did found
it and i've been president for the last
25 years and i wanted to stop by and let
you know i'll be running for president
it's been good meeting you and uh i wish
you the very best now let's figure out
how to
destroy him destroy him
tomorrow is vivies and my big 20-day
anniversary
almost a habit
no oh man then a gondola ride along the
gowanus canal oh no no no no no no no
skywriter is gonna write charles loves v
okay first of all charles loves v means
something very specific
vagina but more importantly you're going
full boil
what i am not oh no
it gets way too intense way too fast and
it always ends in heartbreak we met on
the subway went out to dinner and i told
her i loved her
and then the barbershop quartet i hired
started to sing and then she broke up
with me yes
i know
trust me this is different i have it
under control got to go jakey
excuse me
are you a detective
oh uh
i'm super dan oh hey and i need to talk
to an officer of the law i'm busy right
now working on this
excuse
[Laughter]
oh gosh i am so sorry
i literally just retired
when a citizen comes in off the street
it is nypd policy to take a statement
this isn't enough of a statement
yes i wanted to inquire about renting
out the statue of liberty for a romantic
evening okay
is there a bed in the torch
i thought maybe we should have a little
chat about how crazy you're acting and
how you're blowing this beyond repair
are you really qualified to give
romantic advice you're not exactly the
king of mature relationship
but i would argue that i am like a
beautiful angel of love who has trouble
finding love for himself admit that you
would see that movie
thank you for your honesty
this is city of angels
i'm nowhere near full boil then prove it
just push your anniversary dinner one
night say vivian tomorrow doesn't work
for me can we reschedule
no problem great
voicemail
god i love how she says the words you've
reached hi vivi it's chuckle buddy
i can't wait to see you my luscious
little breakfast quiche i just want to
draw you a bubble bath and spoon feed
you caviar i think we should open up the
junk checking account oh
it's okay i hung up right after chuckle
bunny
[Laughter]
oh buddy
and i'm not gonna just give up the
presidency you should make me your
campaign manager i was born for politics
i have great hair and i love lying
[Laughter]
how's this one opening joke you know the
toughest part about being a gay black
police officer is
the discrimination
[Laughter]
probably that's great
[Laughter]
the discrimination
found this by the way you wrote mr
charles ludley over a thousand times why
would you take her last name boyle
the last two years i've been directing
all my love at rosa so my emotions just
piled up and now with vivian my feelings
are sprang out at me like a fire hose oh
that is overtly sexual no
i'll text vivian from your phone and
tell her you want it to be a double date
that way i can come with you and hold
your hand then your hand will be on her
butt because my hand will be in our butt
you got to get it together man you need
help
sarge gave me and scully the case what
oh
why did you do that i i know i deserved
it but why
we reassigned our drug case diaz and i
have been working it for three months
remember super dan he's been perching on
rooftops at night secretly taking photos
of drug deals he has thousands of images
and can id the entire network of dealers
what no way
luckily hitchcock and scully didn't mind
i didn't even notice he was wearing a
cape you're a cop you should have
noticed that
ryan jensen born 1899 served in the navy
during world war one
[Laughter]
this may be a different branch
[Laughter]
the obvious place to start would be you
in a silver suit with sunglasses and
roller skates
we'd like to go to the times square
we're brothers
we're all set for the double date
tonight vivian's bringing her friend
bernice
bernice that sounds like a cartoon dump
truck
oh no i don't need any distractions my
mission is to protect you ah crap yeah
he's gonna go full peralta and where is
the sex of the city street we want to
see where carrie and big live imma carry
i think i'ma carry we're both carries
if you feel like you can't handle it we
need a signal i'll do this
and how would you do that naturally
this guy's clean by the way
can we pull over please
i don't know if i could do this listen
to me i am with you all night and
nothing will distract me from my solemn
vader protection dog
let's see her where's bernice oh you too
charlie you look so handsome
this is my friend
uh hello i'm jack tractive
my parents were hippies
let's eat
[Music]
check directive
jake you're a cop i wanted to be a cop
when i was a kid mostly because i love
die hard die hard
really oh
i sleep in a nakatomi plaza security
t-shirt
when i was a kid i had the cutest golden
retriever named rufus that is the most
amazing thing i've ever heard i want to
meet him charles
why don't you tell me about the 10-day
forecast oh
good idea
oh
i'm in grad school i thought about maybe
being a sports reporter but it would be
impossible for me to be objective i love
the nets so much
my mother loves rainy days you should
meet her
excuse me no
signal
what is the longest funeral you've ever
attacked this is stupid
oh that's right her dance troupe
[Music]
did you like it all of you go home
immediately meeting is beginning my
stomach is
in blocks
hey charles remember that dog we found
on the train tracks was it inside out or
just very badly burned inside out yeah
cause there were things on the outside
that definitely should have been on the
inside definition of inside out bingo
excuse us
[Laughter]
oh no jake i can't stop looking at her
butt yeah you are definitely making her
uncomfortable not think you're making
her
i'll take care of everything i'll tell
him it was an emergency thank you
can you make it a work emergency not a
bathroom one kind of want to make it a
bathroom
no
this is a big case and hitchcock and
scully are gonna screw it up i'm sure
they can handle it they have a combined
50 years of experience this morning i
found scully's gun in the freezer in the
frozen yogurt i think he was using it as
a
oh spoon god
he refuses to cooperate with you you
weren't that bad you told him his
superpower was being so embarrassing
that people laughed themselves to death
i'm officer brian jensen
listen to him he has no grubby cars do
you know what gravitas sounds like
greetings
[Laughter]
he hasn't spent the last 25 years
fighting to build this organization
right is that bad i thought you created
agla
maca macapa or whatever
isn't it a good thing that brian jensen
didn't have to struggle for 25 years
just to get up on this stage
he's a great boy working yeah
you know the toughest part about being a
gay black police officer is
the discrimination
[Laughter]
after 25 years of struggle i am no
longer the only member and i look
forward to casting my vote for someone
else that is why i withdraw my name from
consideration as president
congratulations brian
oh
if you screw this up i will impeach you
i wrote the bylaws so i know how to do
it
i'm very happy for you
but i will impeach you if necessary
but he got an emergency call and that is
plausible because we're detectives well
this is a tough case because charlie was
acting so weird tonight mm-hmm
work has been so stressful oh golly
funny story i was walking home and i
pass a pawn shop and then i went into a
trance and now i have this engagement no
i'm gonna go ask vivian to marry me bye
no
what are you doing darryl doing this for
your own good you've gone full boil i'm
helping you out give me that figure i'm
gonna peppers for you pepper spray me i
will ever spray you
[Music]
[Laughter]
so much
[Laughter]
[Music]
look i'm sorry i threw your ring in that
boiling pork water yeah oh sorry pepper
sprayed you i'm sorry i pepper sprayed
you burned like hell right yeah thank
god for that soda
[Music]
i need your help why what happened to
scully and hitchcock they're busy
cleaning hitchcock's ear
yeah this guy number three that's some
hope we brought in
yeah okay we're gonna need to take your
statement spare no detail yeah
okay
it's gonna be okay no it isn't they're
gonna look like drug addicts
love with this woman for real and i'm
gonna go full boil and scare her off no
oh that our eyes look fine
i think we're gonna get robbed
i need to pull over
flat tire
give me your wallet oh my god
a little of the left charles yeah i'm
someone seeing great because of the
pepper spray
drivers in the interrogation room you
ready let's do it
a lot of moving shots at this one yeah
hey i checked your phone there were 100
texts from vivian worried about you a
selfie that i could never unsee and
dozens of voicemails you disappeared
last night and you were acting weird and
and i'm worried it's because i'm moving
too fast huh she's full boiled full
boiled for boiling
[Music]
in the interrogation room
something considerably nicer that is
definitely not platinum you really think
this is a good idea buddy i honestly
don't know but you're definitely not
going to scare her off i say do whatever
makes you happy
[Music]
what really
hell yeah take back what i said about
you being immature
accepted fart monster
oh
okay
yeah yeah this is turning into a live
sex show yeah let's go oh my
god although they can't see us
that was shot different
it's not very different yeah
all righty cool
looks like she's sticking around that's
right series regular who would have
thunk it i thought i was going to end
yeah this episode something jake can ask
her out
the
oh the friend yeah that's right no no
boyle's fiance yeah now the door's wide
open for jake to come steal her away
yeah yeah yeah he can absolutely ask her
out if she if he wants match made in
heaven right there man definitely yeah
they love all to say die hard the the
nets
that's about all he likes all they like
wanted to be a cop at one point yeah
there's a lot of good stuff in here a
lot of great stories
ah
i know what it's like to go full boil
yeah yeah i've been down that road
you guys can
i've been around long enough
you probably know i'm kind of individual
who can
have the capability of going full boil
i've been full boil in the past
one time when i was like
19. yeah i wanted to say okay
one time when i was like 19. i was in uh
this girl
wanted to go out here for so long
in a relationship forever
finally
bam gets out of the relationship sort of
and then
valentine's day rolled around she agreed
to hang out with me i went too far with
the plans oh no she backed out
oh what did you plan
it's too embarrassing to admit oh wow
okay but let's just say i had to change
my name to greg alba after that
that's a pretty big deal i think i
remember now
[Laughter]
we will never speak of this against a
lawsuit and everything what i do is
yeah it was uh yeah i have a restraining
order now
kinky this is the kind of jokes i make
in a time like this that's right
i'm like way too invested in the road
[Laughter]
don't let me go full boil because it'll
end up in legal action
yeah uh i know uh i've been known also
obviously that didn't happen in all
society yeah i do
i do know what it's like when you're
getting way too ahead and you're just
getting way too romantic and uh way too
fast
but you know i do like to reveal that
because they played it just right where
i was like maybe she's full maybe she
this part of me was sitting here going
well you know maybe you gotta find the
woman who will accept full boyle and who
will meet you on that level yeah yeah
but uh they weren't
they weren't
letting you in on how vivian is her name
yeah they weren't letting you weren't
letting you in on that vivian is
uh full boyle herself yeah
so
uh i i was here thinking he's like
scaring her off and like creeping her
out yeah yeah yeah and yeah get so
locked into their perspective boyle and
peralta yeah especially at the dinner
and then you were like is peralta like
creeping them out yeah because when they
both want to go to the bathroom
um
and so when when that happened i was
really convinced like oh no this is the
shit's really going to hit the fan so
that was a surprising reveal to me of
how that all
okay yeah how that all occurred
it's weirdly wrapped in this like
like i guess they didn't do their cop
element it was wrapped into like the not
the drug deal with the whole taxi cab
robert thing yeah
all right like a fun bit doing this
undercover thing while mostly just
talking about the date yeah then coming
back yeah like when that came back
around the end i was like oh they are
doing this for an actual undercover
purpose that's right i love the
childlike quality to it it's very
childlike with boilers and also peralta
and boyle very childlike buddies
love it love the chemistry there but the
story with um the whole they have like
three really good stories in here you
know sometimes they don't all succeed
but there were three really defined
stories here that i thought all really
worked about
and i i would guess the overarching
theme with all of them is
uh
don't
judge the surface
you know seeing past the surface and and
discerning what things actually are
rather than your initial yeah knee-jerk
impression or whatever because you have
that here where he's like boy you're
scaring him off and he got a whole too
is so caught in his own legacy that he
you know doesn't want this guy to become
president he feels threatened his ego is
being tampered with
that was all really funny like i love
this reoccurring bit about how old is
like really hilarious to everyone but
the people i think yeah and people have
brooklyn
outside everyone thinks he's so funny
yeah that was beautiful and it's weird
how they can use that joke twice
and get a big laugh
for two very different reasons this is
the first time it's just it's not a joke
it's just such a sad version of your
expectation but also kind of your exact
expectations this is funny because he's
saying a fact so direct and then so and
it's and it's funny because he thinks
it's a joke but it's not funny and then
and then he tells the joke and everyone
just burst into the laughter like a
staring experience that's so funny it
was really funny and
they do continue to surprise me with
gina having her moments where she
does instill those words of wisdom
because it's true like she you know she
made that she said some really strong
points that i wasn't even thinking about
either that were so obvious of
you know i imagine that probably happens
in a lot of people with organizations
too that are
so meaningful to them and that's why
they found it and so to have this thing
where he learns how to hand it off
it was a really really tender moment but
uh his whole line about
he has no gravy dogs
gravy toss
[Laughter]
yeah because he's so perfectly milky
it's so natural like i love it because
it's like he already has a natural
gravitas and then he lays it on that
much thicker there's no baritone to his
way yeah yeah yeah
that was hilarious yeah dude and and
yeah like a nice acknowledgement of like
the whole reason you built this
organization is because so to make it
not as difficult and horrible for people
to come up and to reach these positions
of you know leadership and whatnot so
like you've done such a good job leading
yeah you don't need to cling to it this
way to to feel secure you know oh so
yeah i mean after a certain point it's
like now you got a new guy here who is
able to not just you know continue to do
the the work and rotation but also
contribute new ideas contribute ways to
make
it grow and uh succeed further past the
limits of past the peak of whatever boil
of whatever holt has probably done
himself so
yeah you know that's a big part of it is
finding the person who can help it grow
and help it expand help it you know with
it like talking about the newer ideas
and stuff and it was great and then also
there's the uh super dance super dan
which also another great one because you
think it's just going to be a punchline
thing and then you end up finding out
he's actually really good at his job
yeah
help them solve the case that they've
been working for three months because he
got actually all the is it still legal
what he's doing
i don't know what i don't i don't know
what the wiggle room is here of being a
sort of vigilante when it comes to these
things the way i took it is because he's
just hiding out on rooftops and
photographing people it's not
he's not putting himself like as
immediately in the line of danger fire
etc as like you know a phoenix jones
who's like out there in the streets like
tussling with these people you know so i
i get so dangerous yeah because i mean
if he gets noticed you know like they
don't seem to be discouraging him from
doing such things no and i think that
probably uh roots in there still not
taking him a million percent seriously
but you know more seriously at the very
least like he's still yeah that was nice
because it's like he's still a punchline
character but at the same time it was
like neat to discover like oh yeah he
really has been doing crucial work yeah
you know and then yeah for for scully
and hitchcock to be able to swoop in and
take that credit you know nah you can't
have that yeah man all three all three
uh story lines were really well done and
i enjoyed the hell out of it another
another fantastic episode from brooklyn
nine-nine pretty so i think there's only
like one episode of this whole season
that i was like absolutely never be
better there's like one episode so far
yeah but every episode just keeps
delivering
guys leave your thoughts down below
hit that like button that means a lot
and uh yeah subscribe and click that
bell to get notified when our brooklyn
nine-nine reactions are up
right now it's been steady with not
getting claims
all right we're
like
three weeks in a row now so yeah because
it was you understand this is
17 weeks and only three weeks in a row
it's been steady
so we're just kind of feeling it out and
maybe we're finally maybe maybe nbc is
like i guess they're cool you know yeah
maybe we've made it to the white list
maybe we made it to the part where
they're not gonna keep doing this so uh
yeah i mean that's why we haven't added
on like even though bad batch has ended
and superman lois has ended there's a
reason we haven't added on another show
because i'm really just trying to feel
out like this
can we do two can we now do too
let's just feel it out for a little bit
longer and see how it goes yeah that
we're all clear yeah worry right
nonsense yeah otherwise we're locked
into a really uh unfortunate position if
it's continues so keep sending the good
vibes up keep sending the good vibes it
must be working to some degree yeah all
right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below and hey also um with all the
support we've been getting there are
some patrons
at our um 10 level who we would love to
give a shout out to
sean don mancini oscar
isaac or academy awards saint peter
pacheco saint joanna saint louis saint
matthew chapter 4 verse 13 mensing rogue
cree
ooh
essay
jay
94
justin throw
steve martin kk kayla waters
you gotta close with me i'm sorry
oh no rosie warren beatty darth yoda
order 66
ruby dynamite
colon powell
no it was what are you doing
ruby dynamite is my name it was dolomite
that kid bye-bye sorry the colon is
coming from inside the house phillips
screwdriver smith jr jen agent smith
matthew melanie leblanc natalie doran
doran
like like duran duran chase the gardener
oh he's
mowing that man down aren't you buddy
eva
drazdikova
like wally a little bit like wally
lulava there you go that's better
thanks guys waiting on a high note there
even you are the best out of all of you
all right
guys
i'll catch you guys soon
[Music]
you